i'm here with drew's newsmen ross
matthews and andrew rannell
[Applause]
all right all right russ take it away
you got the first all right our first
story comes to us from
zambia which is in southern africa fox
news reports a woman
sued her boyfriend for taking too long
to propose to her
all right listen up if you ever want to
do this somebody beat you to it gertrude
who's 26 went to court to call out
herbert who's 28 for wasting her darn
time for the last eight years
they already have a kid together her
family already paid a dowry
which is part of the culture there but
there's herbert twiddle his thumbs
he's not asking her he's not doing it
and a judge when she took him to court
the judge said
nothing they could do the court can't do
anything to force him to get married oh
good
but it does make you wonder like have
you ever been in that position where
it's like
tick tock let's do this uh if not
uh approach the bench i don't know what
would you guys do in this situation
well wait a second 26 yeah like
i mean i had a lot of boyfriends by the
time i was 26.
god not me you know it's not that
that's you still have a lot of time hon
like you're okay
you're gonna be okay well it's gonna be
all right i do think
she means business and she went straight
to the courts
i can appreciate that gertrude is a
no-nonsense gal i'm i'm gonna check in
and see what her future holds oh yeah
but
here's my point of view is if you're not
asking me if we're not doing this move
all
move along don't waste my time i am with
gertrude also you have kids and you're
living together like is that you know
isn't that enough
i don't know i i've had three failed
marriages so i can say that
i'm with him i'm with you drew i feel
like she's probably right to be the next
bachelorette let's be honest
dude let's try it okay guys this next
story really revs my motors
forbes reports that you can now totally
obliterate a car
with a battle tank to get out your
demons in 2020
it's called the rage yard experience
offered by a scrap car
company in the uk and they let you drive
a 61-ton
chieftain battle tank straight into a
car to let out your fury
i know you love this did rage making
what about this
and true does anyone want to just like
[Applause]
randomly
i think you're doing real great drew i
think you keep you together
you seem good you seem good
don't you guys ever want to take it out
on something yeah you know i actually
well you tell me what i was when i was a
kid there used to be this like
i grew up in the midwest and there there
were always these it was called a car
bash
and you could beat up a car with like a
baseball bat
yeah for charity so it's a very similar
i'm glad to see that this is coming back
oh i love this
get your anger out and raise the money
for good
i'm saying hurt something not someone
yeah
you're up next all right so this is a
weird one
airbnb has a new listing so usa today
reports that fao schwartz is offering a
one night sleepover for a family of four
so you can live out your dreams of
playing the giant piano with your feet
like tom hanks and big or you can fall
asleep in the lap of a teddy bear
it's 25 bucks and there's a lottery to
win it
on airbnb.com starting tomorrow
i mean this is like what child wouldn't
want to spend the night
in fao schwartz that's incredible i mean
as a little kid can you imagine how
exciting that was as a grown up i'd
rather spend the night in like a crate
and barrel and like redo the little like
living room set yeah and i wouldn't want
to say that we should
apply because you know we're too lucky
but god would i would not give to spend
a night in fbo sports with andrew and
ross
talk about a girl's dream come true and
by the way
casper is now doing beds for dogs
and i had to get this story in and
squeeze it in because
i think it is so fabulous and they're
right here uh
what do you guys think we could do a
sleepover instead of fao schwartz and
these
uh where'd your dog come here lucy come
here
lucy come here try the casper dog bed
what do you think
oh my god oh it's like a dog
i don't know if she likes it oh my gosh
andrew and ross when you know the world
kind of gets back to normal can we all
please sleep somewhere in a store
and and just have fun together yes
please
thank you so much okay the prom
is on netflix right now it is the feel
good movie of the year
watch enjoy and binge like everybody
[Music]
else
you